you are watching cold fusion on this
channel we often take a look at the
cutting edge of technology but now it's
time to go back sometimes to really
understand just how far we've come we
have to take a look at our past it's
cliche but especially true for
technology in the past 10 years alone
we've seen more changes than ever before
the speed of human technological
advancement has been almost exponential
phones are no longer just phones have
you noticed physical media has all but
disappeared have you noticed the way we
capture and share our memories has
changed have you noticed the collective
information and knowledge of four
billion connected people is in our
pockets for the first time in history
it's becoming more and more clear that
just one device is changing society the
smartphone but what lay before it what
untold stories lay hidden in our past
technological achievements in this
series we will remember the things that
the smartphone replaced episode 1 the
Home Video camcorder
VHS camcorders just got into shape shock
the new sharp slim cam the smallest
lightest full-sized VHS camcorder in the
world
noticeably sleek slim and fat-free with
all the great features of the big
camcorders twelve to one zoom one Lux
shoulder stability and uses VHS tapes
that fit right in your VCR the Home
Video camcorder was a huge part of
family life from the mid 80s all the way
until the mid 2000s our first steps
Christmas family dinners and significant
memories were often captured on this
device when people say camcorder you
often might imagine a bulky slab with a
lens that you slide over your shoulder
what many people forget is that this was
actually a slim down simplified version
of a home video system originally home
video recorders were sold as cameras
connected to a separate recording device
this is the sharp portable video
cassette and camera system everyone's
been talking about this system sold
nationally for 1249 dollars we're
liquidating our entire inventory
immediately so we've slashed our price
to just $6.99 yep six hundred ninety
nine dollars was the discounted price so
really any time you wanted to shoot a
video you'd have to run around with a
heavy VCR over your shoulder it's much
simpler today in 1983 Sony finally
solved this by releasing the BMC 100 P
system this was the first ever truly
portable camcorder it used Betamax tapes
which was Sony's higher quality version
of a VHS tape Sony's Betamax tapes at a
higher resolution a more stable image
and could be recorded over numerous
times before there's any noticeable
image quality loss unfortunately the
Betamax format ultimately failed to take
off due to a 60-minute time limit
so how did these cameras actually
perform well in thanks to youtuber
Daniel Lachlan we have some 2013 footage
taken on a typical mid-80s camcorder
there's a certain charm to that picture
isn't it in this other video we see low
light performance ghosting was often a
problem with things such as car lights
and street lights because the sensors
are only capable of a threshold of 10
lakhs
that's about as bright as street
lighting some of the top smartphones
nowadays like the Nokia Lumia 920 and
1020 can go down to about 5 lakhs that's
about the same brightness as a candle
half a meter away by the mid 80s smaller
tape sizes like the video 8 and VHS C
formats were released by Sony and JVC
respectively
however many people still preferred
full-size VHS camcorders mainly because
you could put the tape straight into
your VCR after recording by the mid to
late-1990s
the camcorder went digital small
magnetic tapes are still used for
storing digital video because meaningful
flash storage was still almost a decade
away speaking of the next decade when I
was in my second year of high school in
2004 I remember being in the unique
position of using a VHS tape camcorder
for that year and by the next year which
switched to digital camcorders it was
much easier to edit than tape but I do
remember being extremely unimpressed
with the quality the video and even
audio was heavily compressed in order to
fit on a huge 256 megabytes flash card
for this reason DVD camcorders became a
bit of a thing in the early 2000s is
this the best the digital video industry
can do for digital storage well I don't
think so and I don't think the Canon
things so either
so a new camera made by Canon and it
takes these little mini DVDs as you
could imagine a vertical spinning disc
wasn't the most error-free way of
recording in bumpy situations by 2005 we
began to see smartphones with actual
megapixel cameras one of which was the
sony ericsson k7 50 i which I proudly
owned but sadly the video quality was
still far away
replacing a home camcorder of any kind
look at that
it wasn't until 2009 with phones like
the HTC hd2 that we really began to see
phones that were good enough for home
video news today phones have optical
image stabilization manual zoom and can
record in 4k ultra-high definition or
slow motion video it goes without saying
that society is happy just using their
phones to take home videos of their kids
and other important memories it's now
your PC hard drive or online sites such
as Facebook that are becoming the new
video library for home videos it's just
amazing to think that what used to cost
thousands of dollars and weigh a few
kilograms now fits on your finger now
and literally cost less than a few
dollars to manufacture and that's not to
mention that it performs a lot better
than the cameras of the old generation
next time you pick up your phone you
might just appreciate the video camera
app just that little bit more hello so
thanks for watching the whole way
through guys that was just a pilot
episode of a new series I'm just
planning let me know your thoughts and
the scripts and anything you liked or
didn't like and I might try and
incorporate that in the next video
just as a side point this series isn't
actually going to replace the videos I
do on this channel it's just going to be
every once in a while kind of thing but
anyway please don't forget to like and
share if you did like it and if you're
new here might as well subscribe because
I'm pretty sure you might enjoy some
stuff around here anyway I'll see you
again soon for the next video Cheers are
you thinking
you